[Music]
yeah i'm good chin what's up monday
morning february 7th
it is gonna be the thickest week ever
for your boy hashtag no days off can't
stop won't stop
uh wasn't planned like that it's just
sometimes uh
you have a huge ufc you have the super
bowl and you have
guys in town and you just gotta get the
crew together and everybody has to
hustle your boys working literally
monday tuesday wednesday thursday friday
saturday
and super bowl sunday
no days off i do like to be busy but
jesus christ
uh
just to give you a run down the schedule
little glimpse
into my chaotic life
on top of being a father
is uh
today we have the shop show and we have
fire and the kid
tomorrow we have king in the sting with
a very special guest
wednesday we have fighter and the kid
thursday
we have a food truck with a very special
guest who's in town for the super bowl
and then i'm also doing uh
another big show that's not part of
think boy network outside of this
friday
we have a food truck and a classic fight
companion with a very close and special
guest
saturday
we have the fight companion for ufc 271
izzy style bender arasanya vs whitaker
ii
and we have the whole crew there callan
dalia
special guest special guest that'd be a
big one then sunday
we have a super bowl
companion but it is very different than
what you're used to
this will be at a different location
with some big boys involved some big
guests and i'll announce that as we get
closer uh that is a thick boy production
also collabing with an even bigger
production
uh but it won't be that thick boy it
will be
at this crazy environment so i'm looking
forward to that man so when i say work
it is work but it's also i got the best
gig in the world so i'm excited for this
week man and the team we just got to
buckle down i told these boys the real
the start of thick boy uh the journey
starts january 1st because prior to that
i was in a show time and you know we'd
do a vlog or you know something on think
boy but really when moving all the shows
over and you got a network and then we
just watched launch cats after dark if
you haven't seen that it's available
right now on thick boy so cats after
dark it was a show that was on patreon
uh
years a year ago yeah a couple years ago
maybe a couple years ago and it's all
the king this thing alumni you got chin
on there you got cat on there you got
backflip lacy on there you got meatball
uh kyle
so and special guest and then obviously
nick davis the producer who i love
and uh that's available
so this first one we gave you guys and
then moving forward you'll half of it
will be on thick boy the other half uh
will be exclusively on super cast so to
sign up for the super casts really easy
all you got to do is go to thickboy.com
you'll see a link for premium content go
there you're off to the races you have
every show i do ad free you have bonus
content on there my new vlogs go on
there the rest of cats after dark goes
on there there's a bunch of cool content
on there so go check it out man and uh
yeah we're rolling baby we are rolling i
was in atlanta over the weekend atl
shout out to atl
uh
freezing
i i'm not gonna lie to you it was
freaking freezing out there when you
think like dirty south you don't really
think of cold dude it i haven't been
that cool not know how long couldn't
tell you how long
this is us um
so sober
it's thick the water's overflowing
the water's overflowing
my favorite comment is your bell where
the bubbles at though
not the bubbles just three grown men in
a bathtub dog
so the the airbnb stayed in buckhead so
the airbnb had this it was a great
airbnb had this gorgeous pool and hot
tub and then uh you know i've always
wanted to try uh
oh this is funny um
someone said i hope that's not ketchup
with the wings where's the ranch i don't
do ranch any of that [ __ ] again i was
already
you know cheating on my carnivore diet
which i haven't cheated on at all
and uh
you know hear about magic city and their
wings and i'm not going to go i don't
need to be in that environment
so i order it from postmates
but
i couldn't wait to get off stage and
order it
dude just for 50 wings it was
115 for 15 wings
and then i got the uh pork or no i'm
sorry the lamb chops i mean a lot of
lamb right now on this corner carnivore
diet
um and so i got the
the lamb chops as well
those are the best lamb chops i've ever
had in my life hands out for a cheat
meal it had like this a1
homemade sauce with the lou williams uh
like weird
honey mustard hot sauce my word dude my
word it was fantastic
this is interesting though so
[Music]
the original post said checked one off
the thick boy bucket list
if lou williams can risk his mba career
on some chicken wings i can cheat on my
diet
i don't think i'm that famous in any
facet wouldn't consider myself
celebrating any facet not even remotely
close i don't even think people will see
this stuff i really do it for my friends
and for the fans coming to the shows and
say atlanta thing
so i posted lee lou williams and i
didn't know
uh my boy who helps me with social media
was going to tag him and then lou
williams goes you all need to stop with
this narrative never risk my career for
wings please stop respectfully
so he's cool yeah so i was like oh
[ __ ] i was like my batman dm'd him we're
all good the fans lit him up though i
wanted back to you just just be cool man
you know
uh he didn't risk his career for that
remember they were in the uh the bubble
and he went to a funeral and after the
funeral his they have literally they
named the wings after him i don't know
if he eats it so much he created the
recipe i don't know what
but so he went there to eat after the
funeral you know that's all this is it's
not a risk clearly a joke mr lou clearly
a joke hell of a player a lot of love
for you man and your wings dude i would
have risked my career for those wings
so in atlanta
i [ __ ] with them on this in atlanta
you know if you go to buffalo wild wings
or certain places the wings are real fat
and big i hate them when they're too big
it's almost like a [ __ ] medieval
times like turkey like i don't like that
so for more taste they have them smaller
and man those wings are smaller they're
they're fan now are they better than jts
in arizona
i'd have to have jt's right away but i
would say no but they're [ __ ] up
there man now 105 dollars plus delivery
fee come on medic city now i assume when
you're there and you have titties in
your face and a thong they're even
better
but i've told the story before you know
why
they don't uh like rick ross and then
want to dry rub lemon pepper because
they want to be at strip club and still
be able to grab masses so you can't have
hot wing sauce over your hands they came
with the dry rub it's brilliant it's
brilliant brilliant
so yeah man so shout out to atlanta mac
city shout out to that hot tub
um
it was a it was a grand old time went to
a mall there um i forget the name of
them all dude i've never seen more
security in my life we walked in it was
30 security guards like and i don't mean
like you know those mall security were
like dude if something breaks out you
guys are [ __ ] yeah there was a few of
those guys this small white guy here you
don't have a gun he goes now yo dude
that has to be stressful
so
there's like i'm saying like
presidential [ __ ]
security everywhere ar-15s there's dogs
and i'm like is there something going
down here i don't know about then one of
the guys was a fan he's like b shot what
are you doing here man y'all my tour i
said hey man let me ask you something
what the [ __ ] up with all the security
yes oh you don't know you don't know
about this mario no it was the nicest
mod i've ever had gucci louis vuitton
saint laurent all you know dope food
court all the written like nice mall
nice small and he goes oh no they're
shootings every week here man and he
goes he was the boys were slitting
throats in the bathroom
oh check please
check please the mall i don't need a fly
outfit this bad i'm out
it was nuts
nuts atlanta was great punchline atlanta
fantastic club i used to play a theater
out there i play the bucket theater i
just love getting reps i love clubs that
club it's a smaller club feels like a
strip club it's next to a diner so it's
just this cool like i don't know like
grungy
grungy vibe i dig it man i dig it
um
let's get to the fights we had a big
fight weekend the ufc has been edginess
for weeks now before this big paper u
ufc 271 which i cannot wait for which
we'll get into
but prior to this you had a big fight in
the middleweight division
because you had sean strickland who um
you know told you guys i'm a huge fan of
this kid i think he wears his heart on
his sleeve i think he's one of the few
that actually speaks how he actually
feels
for good or bad not that i agree with
him every time especially on a lot of
stuff but at the end of the day at least
he's authentic i don't think it's a bit
i don't think it's pretty conceived i
think he just shoots and fires from the
hip which i appreciate can get you in
trouble obviously uh very good friend
joe rogan is dealing with that right now
and i would love to get into that and
i'm i will do on firing the kid get them
to have my thoughts on there i think
it's hilarious these comedians after
staying quiet when he helped them out so
much and other complete [ __ ] but
we'll get to that later don't get me
started right now i just want to talk
about fighting let's take a little break
from me ranting about god knows what
because man the nfl season is coming to
an end but it's going out with a big
bang we're talking about the super ball
this sunday watch it watch the super
ball companion thick boy with my special
guests but also make money with
draftkings sportsbook the official
sports bank partner of super ball 56.
all right they have a super offer for
new customers get 50 61 odds on either
team but just five dollars or more and
get 280 and free bets if your team wins
i think the rams are going to win but
i'm not mad if since he does but i do
root for the rams betting on mma is more
of your thing cool draftking sportsbook
also has tons of ways to bet saturday's
big ufc 271 fight card in houston it's
going down saturday so you can make bank
on saturday at uc 271 you can make bank
on sunday all right with the super bowl
all right download the draftkings
sportsbook app right now use promo code
shobb s-e-h-a-b bet just five dollars or
more on either super bowl 56 team and
get 280 in free bets if they win that's
promo code shobb at draftkings
sportsbook the official sportswear
partner of super bowl 56.
must be 21 or older minimum age and
location requirements vary by
jurisdiction see draftkings.com
sportsbook for a full list of
requirements in state-specific
responsible gaming resources voidware
prohibited gambling problem call 100
gambler in tennessee call or text
tennessee redline 1-800-889-9789
in connecticut call 888 789
or visit
ccpg.org
chat in new york call
8778
hope ny or text hope ny
467-369 if you're still listing download
draftkings app right now promo code shop
to bed on the super bowl and ufc 271
listen man i was just in atlanta and i
noticed one thing a lot of your brawls
are losing your hair man a lot of your
dudes losing your hair yep two out of
three men will experience some form of
hair loss by the time they're 35. that's
my demo 8236 bros more than 50 million
bros will suffer from male pattern
baldness my brother is not a big deal
told me get on keeps man keeps officer
simple stress-free way to keep your hair
all right convenient virtual doctor
all right the medication is delivered
straight to your door every three months
so you don't have to leave your crib
low-cost treatments are just ten dollars
per month keeps offers generic versions
discreet little package shows up proven
results so you know you're good you also
don't need to give away your secret
while you're looking like fabio in a few
months man prevention is key treatments
can take four to six months to see
results so act right now to be honest if
you're ready to take action prevent hair
loss go to keeps.com
that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
s-e-h-a-u-b to receive your first month
of treatment for free that's keeps.com
shob to get your first month free
k-e-e-p-s dot com shop uh so with sean
strickland i'm a huge fan uh we'll get
him on the show out here but he uh
you know he's won six in a row now in
the middleweight division
listen if izzy gets past robert
whittaker which i think you will and
i'll get into that uh uc 271 card after
this but if if izzy were to get past
whitaker there's not a lot of formal
opponents man there's just not a lot
going on that gets you excited sean
strickland gets me a little excited you
know i don't think he can go toe-to-toe
talent wise with izzy but he you know
with sean strickland no one's really
figured him out man no one really has
figured him out he can stick behind a
jab and his jab's fantastic
you know i people no one solved this
puzzle i think it's hilarious the judges
gave a split decision in what [ __ ]
world was that a split decision
i mean this was a
easily you know 50 46 fight easily i
mean if you want to get 49 46 i guess
and no disrespect to jack the joker her
manson but uh he just got out class i
thought sean strickland his jab was
brilliant um
i think for a guy that's trying to get
to where he's going which is i assume
being a world champion
do you need these type of fights jack
hermansen is no punk he's a very very
good fighter he's a guy you know who's
coming off a big win off of shabazzian
and you know that's no punk either so
her manson is no joke man so to get the
ring time in there five minutes and
dominate and really let's say you lost
one round but to win four to one
these are the steps you need to get to
the world championship level i actually
like this for sean strickland's career i
know he's very hard on himself during
the post-fight interview um i think a
little bit of that is him
listening to social media and listening
to his critics and i think you want to
get out there and put on a fantastic
fight and knock this guy out and i get
all that that's why we love him but as a
fan of sean strickland wanting to see
him achieve what he's
set out to do
you need fights like this i can't have
you go out there and starch everybody uh
especially on a five
five uh fight win streak
these are good for you sean this being
in there with a veteran a beast and jack
hermansen and outclass them for [ __ ]
25 minutes
is it's just it's an investment man it's
like you invested it's like you invest
in crypto right right now it's cut in
half it's a long term play it's gonna
bounce back this is a long term play you
invest in your career you went five
rounds you totally outclass them nobody
can break can figure out this rubik cube
that is sean strickland at middleweight
six wins in a row you know hard has to
win six [ __ ] fights in a row in the
ufc he's be good guys too man he's not
like he's being scrubs he's being
quality opponents he's out classroom his
jab is filthy you know uriah hall it's a
tough puzzle to figure out he beat him
jotco tough guy brendan allen super
tough
so
you know he has three decisions in a row
right now
but
i think sean strickland is one of these
guys that people are gravitating towards
right now in a world full of just
smoke and mirrors
[ __ ] fake news
sean strickland for good or bad is gonna
give you what he thinks and it's
refreshing i think the world needs it i
think that's why he's a fan favorite
right now
and i don't think a title shot is next
for him i think after beating jack
hermansen and really he hasn't had any
issues in his last you know six fights
so now now it's time to
put your money where your mouth is and
you can get the big boy big fights you
know i could easily see for him uh a
marvin vittori and to be honest
if i'm matchmaker i go paulo costa paulo
costa interesting for sean strickland is
a fantastic fight the build-up's
fantastic
i just think um
as a fan of sean strickland i think he
can beat paulo casa i don't think he
finishes them but i think he beats him
decision um
and even marvin vittori depends what
they want to do marvinette 2 is tough i
think the winner of jared cannon air
derrick brunson gets a title shot
especially if derrick were to win that
fight
i really think if derek brunson wins
that fight he's the title shot um that's
obviously this weekend so
you know i think sean strickland is a
little too hard on himself
you know i know he wants to go out there
and please the fans and you know be on
sports center top 10 stuff like that but
this stuff is good for you man this
stuff is good for you it's like uh
there's been a lot of nfl references
today but there's like it's like you
know in the nfl like you want those
those close games where
you know even though you might have been
up 21 to nothing they came back and
that's the fourth quarter you got to put
together two minute drive you want those
challenges before you get to the
playoffs and this is all this is that
was a challenge he's going to get to the
playoffs and when he gets to the
playoffs you're in costa you inventory
you got izzy there you got jared
cannonair you got jeff brunson so derek
derek brunson my friend jeff brenson uh
good buddy shout out to jeff brunson but
you got derrick brunson so you know you
got the dogs are waiting for him and you
know sean strickland's a tough guy to
figure out
but i thought this is good for him i
really do i think this is absolutely
perfect for him and the steps he's going
to and hopefully can afford uh some new
blinds in his apartment
you know i love seeing that stuff though
he's just a fighter spider man
i can't i became the biggest fan of him
when we played the video i've always
been a fan of him but i became the
biggest fan
when uh that guy was like road raging
with him and he was like dude i'm down
to fight no no weapon guns no guns yep
no guns i love that man
that's how it should be exactly
a man uses these not these anybody can
pull that
but to be like dude i'm down like you
have an issue let's do it old school
[ __ ] man guys [ __ ] i love that dude we
need more sean strickland's in the world
you know
so yeah i think he's gonna get a big boy
next and then once the ufc gets the
marking machine behind him you know it's
off to the races for sean strickland and
i wonder if they're gonna try and clip
his wings as far as what he says and
[ __ ] like that it doesn't seem like
they're doing that no yeah not yet not
yet
i think you know
if you were to become champ you know you
don't a champion like you know i want to
kill a guy in there and stuff like that
you know they usually frown upon that
but
you know
you know what you're getting with them
which i love
i absolutely love there was a nasty um
submission
yeah right
i'll show you right around here
dennis bondar
or bondar
i will just play this clip right here
so it wasn't even a submission it was
more of a
huge we have like a whizzer underhook
they call him flash gordon
that's a shame the scream in pain
oh
that's dislocated not broken
not going to be fun though definitely
sort of and i heard that this guy came
off of like two years from an injury and
just got this happened to him
it's a bummer yeah so they said they
called it sort of like he was going for
an arm bar
huh and then right when you push them to
the fence that's when it comes out yeah
jesus christ
that's not fun that's pretty nasty
yeah it's a dislocation i think it's
broke definitely strain the ligaments
though you know absolutely
yeah but uh overall it was good for sean
strickland fan of sean strickland you
want that stuff you don't want a guy
just starching everybody
it's kind of like when uh
with anthony joshua mary's starch
everybody then we fought klitschko that
made one of the i think top three
heavyweight boxing matches of all time
and remember you know he's kind of doing
his thing again it is an older clitcho
and he's doing it and then he gets
[ __ ] dropped and then pops back up
and then the back and forth and he beats
him remember that like
it's tough for me to invest in a fighter
when they've never faced adversity it's
tough for me to go all in on a guy who's
never been sat down and who's never been
humbled it's very very tough to invest
in that fighter and uh i i i think it's
good man i think certain steps where you
have to look at yourself in the mirror
and recalculate because you learn
nothing when you're just starting people
i'm telling you you learn absolutely
nothing
you learn nothing as a fighter you gotta
have those days where you like all right
well that didn't work exactly how we
thought and go back to the drawing board
because when you start your it's like
i guess we just keep doing what we're
doing
it worked and then then you're gonna run
into somebody where it doesn't work and
you should have fixed those things
four fights ago but you can't because
you never learn anything they run to a
guy who you can't starch you know and
sometimes you're at such a high level
where it's impossible to fix those
mistakes and you're trying to but then
they throw you this guy trust me from
personal experience i was starch and
dude starch and dude starch and dudes
and then they're like here's no guerra
and we're like wishing keep doing what
we're doing
and then he doesn't fall right away and
he's in the pocket and then you lose and
then it's like all right we got to
change some things up but you're at a
certain level where there's no going
back and then ufc goes well here's ben
rothwell i guess i'll see if these
changes we made in camp work against a
guy who's 40 fights more experienced
than me and then then you lose to him
and then it's like you know then it's
where do you go from there you know but
if that if that stuff would happen early
in my career you can make those changes
and you had a level where you can try it
out you know you can try it out you can
try new material out um because you
don't want to do it during a special
because you don't know if the new
material is going to work so that's all
this is it's good for sean strickland i
think you'd watch and go [ __ ] i have a
really good jab i can win just off the
job if i have to just off footwork if i
have to it's good for him
uh so you have ufc
271 this saturday we have a fight
companion with crystallia brian kell
myself and a very
special guest potentially two special
guests
uh i love this card man from top to
bottom absolutely love this card
you know i'll see the the big boys at
the top we got izzy versus robert
whitaker too uh robert wicker since that
loss has gone on for you know
again he learned from that fight he's
talked about you know what happened
going into that fight and he's made some
changes and you know um
[Music]
it's proof's in the pudding you look at
his last three fights um since his loss
to izzy he's definitely fighting smarter
more strategic um and it's paying off
for him
you know
i think again i'mma correlate this back
to football you know how tough it is to
beat the same team twice look at the
odds of being the same team twice it's
not good it's very it's very tough to do
because
you create a game plan that team sees
the game plan
and then
they can't go with the same game plan in
the second game they got to make
adjustments because that team
is going to be ready to beat that
original game plan so you both have to
make adjustments so you get a different
fight so for izzy i would say this is
his toughest challenge at middleweight
obviously at light heavyweight yawn was
a very difficult challenge we'll get to
that but i think for robert whittaker
he knows what izzy's going to do we know
what izzy's going to do
the x factor here is rob what is robert
whittaker going to do and he's made
changes his camp and we've seen it in
his last three fights where he is a more
strategic better fighter
and i i heard robert whitaker and uh
other interviews say you know i think
jan blockovich kind of gave the
blueprint how to beat izzy
i think he's making a huge mistake
thinking that
his game plan at middleweight will work
the same as it worked for yom blockovich
who walks around 240 pounds
i think he's making a huge mistake if he
thinks
that he's going to have
the same success on takedowns that yom
blokovic had at 240 pounds against a
lighter izzy
i think he's making a mistake
if he thinks
oh all you got to do is the the
it's out the cat's out of the bag you
get izzy down the middle of the cage
you know you got to wait for izzy make
him come to you that's what yon did i i
got to make sure i don't take him down
against the cage because he's really
good at wall uh crawling or he's good at
the defense take down against the cage
i get all that and i realized yawn had
success with that
nobody in the middleweight division is
yan blockovich none of you are not even
remotely close you have the same skill
set you have the same power you don't
have the same power in your hands that
scares izzy you don't have the same
control you don't have the same demeanor
you don't have the same and biggest of
all star this size advantage that fight
was a size advantage thing
and i think it's weird that people
criticize izzy for shooting for the
[ __ ] moon trying to beat a young
blokovic who's a giant man who is a
nightmare of a match up for izzy and he
failed he failed and there's nothing
wrong with that but now izzy critics
think they've seen a hole in his game
and want to go oh all you got to do is
take him down the middle of the cage and
then all you got to do is wait for him
to come to you
i think it's easier said than done and
also for robert witter's camp
if you don't think his team's looking at
that and going okay this is what they
think we're gonna do okay this is what
they think the holes are are in our game
if you don't think they're working on
that if you don't think he realizes that
you guys are gonna try to implement the
same game plan you're out of your mind
there's a reason why he's a three-time
world champion at middleweight and he's
going for his fourth defense of the
title man you don't get to that level
without having the highest iq possible
in the game and not only you're dealing
with iq of izzy you're dealing with iq
of his team that would be pretty [ __ ]
good we can list off the alumni on his
team and they're all monsters man and
they all function at a very very high
level
so what i a little red flag for me is
robert whittaker's team going i think
the cat's out of the bag you take him
down in the middle of the octagon you
don't try and take him down against the
cage you wait for him to come to you
okay
okay
and i do you know robert whitaker talked
about the pressure of being champ and
you know and that stuff and being a
father and and dealing with all that and
and i do understand that i do think he's
looked better in his past three i do
think this would be a much different
fight i think it's to be a hell i think
it's be as fire the year written all
over it i really do uh it could go to
decision i think you know izzy does drop
him but i think the will and the power
of robert whittaker he's going to get
back to his feet i don't know if he gets
finished if he does it's the biggest
accomplishment in izzy's career because
again
we know what izzy's gonna do and his
team's obviously gonna make adjustments
because robert whittaker's talking about
you know take downs and take him down
center to the octagon it's easier said
than done
but i do think izzy's gonna get the very
very best version of robert whitaker i
think he's getting an absolute hell of a
fight in robert whittaker but i i do
think izzy rises to the challenge
because
you'll notice and there's another
gentleman's card who also has an issue
with this
when you're champ heavy lies the crown
frank mayer has talked about this ronda
rousey's talked about this uh shane
carwin you all these
other
champions have talked about how when
you're a champion everyone's getting for
you and you have other you know outlet
and you got to do interviews and
marketing and you're the face of this
it's just a different
trajectory it's a different kind of
path than the rest of the the ufc roster
there's a lot of stress there's a lot of
mental warfare there's a lot of pressure
on you certain guys do fantastic with it
they really do certain guys eat this up
camaro usman i think francis if they
mark them right would deal with it right
um i mean he is dealing with it right
you know you look at volkanovsky you
look at certain champions who who
they
they can
deal with it mentally better than
anybody else a chuck liddell did or
randy couture anderson silva a gsp
probably the best he didn't let any of
it get to him they can compartmentalize
they can put it over here and deal with
the pressure
certain guys can't and robert wick has
said that it's very difficult for him he
doesn't do well with all the pressure
and that's fine and i actually think the
pressure's not even remotely on robert
whitaker for this fight all the pressure
on is on izzy
but if you ask izzy he wouldn't want it
any other way you're talking about a guy
that walks out with
you know b-boy dancers and has those
infamous walk-outs you know uh
the tribute to his african heritage and
all that stuff you thought i'm a guy
when the camera's on
flourishes and is the best version of
himself
certain guys aren't the best version of
themselves when the lights are on it's a
[ __ ] good version and they can be 99
of the world but they can't beat the the
tip of the spare guys like an izzy and
it goes to the same thing goes for this
co-main event in derrick blackbeast
lewis against tied to avasa i absolutely
love this fight if you remember after
derrick lewis's last fight and tied to
avastas i said this is a fight to make i
would love to see this fight
it doesn't make sense when you look at
the rankings it doesn't make any sense
in the world just makes sense from an
entertainment standpoint it also makes
sense for taitu avasta to [ __ ] or get
off the pot in regards to being a world
beater right so if you're a thai to
avasta fan which they're going to be a
bigger fan i'm going to show you with
them i swallowed this loogie i feel sick
talking about it right now i've done a
shoei with the infamous tai tu avasa i
[ __ ] love that guy but for tai
tuavasa
ranked 11
to catapult all the way and fighting
number three is a big jump and this is
the ufc
trying to figure things out because with
derrick lewis you know
uh two fights ago against cyril gone in
his hometown and i think the ufc made a
mistake here because they didn't realize
what
brings out the best of derrick lewis
putting a fight in his hometown putting
all the pressure on him having to fight
a cyril gone
he even said i i don't like the pressure
i don't like fighting five rounds i
don't like when all the eyeballs are on
me i don't like any of that [ __ ]
so the best version of derek lewis is
not
when he's fighting the top of the spare
guys the francises the steep bays when
he's fighting those monsters the serial
guns
it he he you're getting a different
version of derrick lewis man he doesn't
like being the main event
but co-main event derek lewis
the derrick lewis that doesn't have to
worry about doing a million interviews
and carrying the belt around and all
that pressure a co-main event there
glows for three rounds
might be the best heavyweight on the
planet
but that's not the way the business is
structured if you want to be the best
you'll be able to fight five rounds when
all the chips are stacked against you
when all the eyeballs are on you he
doesn't like that that's fine
but anybody not named sierra gone stipe
or francis
ranked [ __ ] three or under
ain't beating derek lewis man it's a
nightmare of a [ __ ] matchup because
he shows up because that same pressure
isn't there he can be himself and boy
you know i think i do think francis hits
harder but
[ __ ] derek lewis is right [ __ ] there
man and when you look at the styles of
derrick lewis and tai tuavasa
there's no other way to put it it's
cliche you're talking about two knockout
artists if this fight goes to decision i
will freak the [ __ ] out there's not a
chance taito vasa has that no [ __ ]
giving
gene in his body
derek lewis has that but it's a little
more calculated he definitely has it but
it's more calculated
uh and the odds rightfully so
to me take your coin and flip it up in
the air and that's who you should bet on
derrick lewis minus 180 tied two of us a
plus 155 these are the odds make you're
flipping the coin like
geckos has a little more power like if
this is a video game derrick lewis power
10 tattoo vasa 9.5
whoever lands first whoever's gonna take
the risk they can't trade one for one
because you get a double knockout
it's it's whoever kind of you know gets
there and implements somewhat of a game
plan and lands that first big bomb and
derek lewis has been in those big fights
this is a huge jump up for tai tuavasa
i'm rooting for him my god am i rooting
for him but all the ufc is doing
this is what the ufc is doing all right
derek doesn't be a main event derek's
never gonna be our champ most likely and
if francis leaves he could be if he gets
over this kind of
you know mental
issue with being the champ and the
pressure and all that stuff so he might
be champ but also when you look at tai
two of us and derek lewis
they're on
completely different sides of the earth
one's from new zealand one's from
[ __ ] houston once a black guy one's
[ __ ] what is he
polynesian new zealand whatever they are
over there both thick boys you have two
thick boys from different parts of the
world
they're
they're the same guy
they're the same guy skill wise power
wise i give derek a little bit of
advantage some of the greatest knockouts
we've seen
but still they're kind of the same guy
now derrick has fought better
competition but the ufc's tried their
shot at making them champ the interim
belt right francis
cyril he's fought everybody ty hasn't
fought everybody
so
i'm assuming the ufc matchmakers go all
right if tai wins we'll just plug him at
three
they're the same guy
we just we know he's not gonna take guys
down
we know he's not gonna you know be a
boring decision unless it's francis and
that was a whole nother ordeal but we
know you know certain things that he's
gonna get it done so i think
you know for thai kind of [ __ ] off the
pot time because you look at his record
you know who's who's the best guy that
he's beat
it's tough you know he fought a vet and
andre alaska went to decision that was a
close fight he lost to june to santa
junior dos santos he left the ivanov
what i don't know what happened to him
he lost ivanov he lost to sergey
um you know steven stefan struve but we
know stephanie's true one foot out that
one giant leg out the door
um the greg hardy fight okay
sakai you know tough guy no doubt
knocked him out so this is them you know
trying to
trying to figure out if they can
you know put stock in tied to avasa it's
the biggest jump up and he hasn't passed
that test yet that junior santos they're
tr huge that would have been his
you know quick pass to a uh you know be
in the top five he didn't pass the hat
so he's gone on to win some fights now
and now this is their second attempt to
be like all right
if derek loses again you know we know he
does he doesn't want to be that champion
material maybe tied to avasta's guy
they're the same guy
one knocks everybody out the other
knocks everybody out one's great on the
mic the other is great on the mic one
does shoeies the other just gives fire
[ __ ] promos we can market it at all
so that's what they're doing
this is what they're doing
they're the same guy um then the third
fight on the card is a banger jared
kenner derek brunson i love derek
brunson he's been on food truck blonde
derrick brunson is a [ __ ] he
wants that rematch with izzy i do think
he's a different fighter he derek's a
guy who's been fighting forever if
you're a jorge maslow fan i think a lot
of jorge's fan base obviously comes from
him with these huge fights and starch
and dudes and get on the mic and you
know three-piece and a soda where the
hell he said
brunton is the same thing
but he's not you know of cuban descent
from miami but brenton has been fighting
for [ __ ]
ever
and he's one of the good guys that you
want to see
win you want to see him get a huge
payday
he he he's one of the guys that have
been doing this from the ground up man
he's been fighting when was his first
fight chin
dude no
he's fought everybody
pro 2010
so he's been fighting for 12 years
and you're talking
he fought in uh
world extreme fighting he was in
strikeforce challengers forever and then
he got to the ufc in 2012 so he's been
10 fights in the ufc he's fought chris
levin beat him yo romero lorenz lark and
he beat him ed herman beat him sam alvey
beat him uh uriah hall beat him lost for
robert whitaker lost anderson silva
although that los angeles was dicey some
people think he won he beat machida off
uh punches he lost to jock ray lost to
izzy he beat uh the dime piece in
theradoro he beat ian highness she beat
shabazzian who's you know especially at
the time was a [ __ ] monster he beat
kevin holland who's a monster he beat
darren till you know so it's just like
you root for these guys man he's earned
it and i'm not saying jared kennedy has
any time again he fought at [ __ ]
heavyweight um you know he's been
fighting since 2011. so you're talking
about two good dudes
you know at heavyweight he fought
[ __ ] sean jordan which is insane um
he fought glover he lost to jan lost don
mcgregor's beat david branch beat
anderson silva with the light kicks uh
he beat jack hermeson he be he lost to
robert whittaker
so
he beat calvin gaslim which is
impressive the thing about this though
is
he fought um
robert whittaker two years ago so i
don't think if cannon air wins
um he's gonna get a title shot
especially if robert whittaker will be
able to pull this off you're not going
to do that rematch you're just not
you're just not
you know if robert worker to win you
izzy automatically gets a a rubber match
you'd have to
so i think if robert whittaker loses
izzy wins your next fight is probably
most likely going to be jeff
or dick brunson
um
and you know for whitaker it's back to
the drawing board you know i'm just i do
have my reservations about people going
especially robert whittaker's camp going
no bloop
blueprints out how to beat izzy easier
said than done man robert wicker does
have a wrestling background i think that
surprises a lot of people he came up in
australia being a hell of a wrestler i
want to was he on the national team jen
the boy can [ __ ] wrestle though
also one of my favorite nicknames bobby
knuckles
so whitaker bank began competing in
freestyle wrestling um turned up to
compete in australia cup he won each of
his three bouts
um he was also at the 215 australia cup
whitaker flag possibility
of representing australia in the
olympics okay
he returned to wrestling in may
uh he claimed the australian national
wrestling championship gold medal so the
boy can [ __ ] wrestle that's at 213
pounds some monsters there after winning
the national championship
whitaker earned australia's 2018
commonwealth games um he would once
again claim first place in the division
this [ __ ] can wrestle
yeah
so he stepped away from wrestling just
to compete in the ufc
and then he was going to compete in the
commonwealth games in 2018 but whitaker
was forced to withdraw from the games
less than three weeks from the event in
order to not risk being stripped of the
ufc championship title that's ridiculous
you see was concerned that injury uh
that an injury occurred during the
commonwealth games would render him
unable to compete
that sucks that's a bummer
i i knew he wrestled i i
you know i know there's talks about him
beyond the national team i didn't know
he's a [ __ ]
monster
so yeah you you his team of c is like
all right homeboy can wrestle it's very
rare he uses it if we can get izzy down
the center octagon i just middle what
you're talking about different animal
man i know everyone's looking at that
205 slip up that he had with jan i think
you're making us
a big mistake you can have your hands
full
and as far as you you force and easy
come to you
is he ain't stupid is he has the best iq
in middleweight division
damn there of all time he's up there and
silva's right there with him but izzy as
far as creativity getting things done
it's just easier said than done man but
people want to talk [ __ ] about his you
know his aspiration become the 205 champ
that you're just talking
almost a different game and i think if
robert whittaker's team goes in there
looking at his wrestling background i
get why you guys can think that but
easier said than done man
everybody since the beginning of time in
izzy's career has decided to take him
down not a lot have achieved that so
we'll see
i think robert
would have to be smart
because
he's
kind of conflict himself there when he
goes you just gotta make izzy come to
you you know you gotta you know get him
to
to come in and apply the pressure
okay but then you also want to be the
aggressor in the wrestling game so it's
a little tough unless the game plan is
the counter which nobody's better in the
world at countering than izzy but if
your game plans to counter izzy and when
he comes in you shoot
i think either said than done i think
easy at 85 is the best we have to offer
for a reason
so we'll see man
good card overall though uh you can
watch it with your boys at 7pm this
saturday calabasas fight campaign with
the boys and a very special guest
again coming to vane is izzy robert
whitaker co-may event i'm super excited
for derrick lewis tied to avasa they
have jared cannon there derrick bronson
kyler phillips rojo bobby green nasrat
is a great fight rooting for bobby green
coming off the big win over ali quinta
and then uh the prelims are fun as well
yeah andre arlovski doing the goddamn
thing still
um roxanne it's her last fight casey
o'neil big fan of casey o'neill she's a
monster so
good fights overall man good fight to
overall what do you got jen
all right going back to what you were
mentioning earlier with uh strickland
and costa which i think is a great fight
costa recently said something about that
yeah so costa said he's only interested
in fighting victoria again
or no one else he's not shooting anyone
else ah you know what's tough about
coastal he makes these demands and he's
not in the power position no and like he
was horrible the last fight too man
terrible missing weight like multiple
times because i said to let uh i just
said to let the
ufc president dana white know uh i'll
fight him now it's the only fight that
interests me no one else in spain unless
just fight for the title but i'm no fool
i'm not stupid consider todd fight right
now all right i want to fight him he's
the only viable guy that interested me
it's not him i'm not even interested in
fighting i let dana white know that ufc
just keeps on keeping on man
it's not victoria there's no one else in
the uc industry i don't i don't respect
him
i want to end his life he's an [ __ ]
full he had this win over me thinks he's
the man but he's an [ __ ] child we see
he's a goof he can't even wear shorts
the right way there's a foot of him with
his shorts backward and he still thinks
he's the man
all right but i'll fight him again i
mean at least i plan to i'm not saying i
want to fight victoria because he took
my place in the ranking it's not about
that it's because he's an [ __ ] i have
to fight him i have to erase this loss i
want to leave him sideline for at least
a year after beating i give him i want
to hurt him i'm angry
then he says boxing pays more in the
short term but doesn't have the
promotion power the ufc has
pointed out the ufc heavyweight uh
francis who's also in contract dispute
with the company over money is worth at
least 20 times more than is to close
disclosed purse okay the ufc pays too
little but has high promotional power
you have to try to have both get what's
best from each side what is
which is what uh francis has done he's
the ufc champion getting paid a bad
purse now that he's at the top he's
doing the right thing which is to go
after the financial products that
all this just lets me know he's not
getting that inventory fight
talking about fighter pay francis
what you got to become champ and leave
the ufc's like all right we're out and
you're making demands that ain't
happening
and this is victoria's response which i
thought was
right on point you was in the cage with
me 30 pounds heavier and for real i know
a [ __ ] her name felicia she it's harder
than you
i think it's been a
transformation translation yeah
yeah he had a shot he missed weight he's
30 pounds over it's like the target
could have easily said like i'm not
taking that fight but he took it and he
beat him still beat him yeah
all right so you could do torrey
strickland if you want
i like costa and i like strickland would
be awesome coastal we'll see if he does
it
so this video is too long but so sean
strickland at the uh
at the post fight he was talking to some
reporter that i guess he said look
feminine like he was talking about like
you know oh yeah you look like you want
to bring you know take me to bed or
something like that but he was very
playful
so you could see his personality order
playful or no oh yeah he said like oh he
said like uh
you know because it's a male reporter
male reporter okay yeah so you know he
just he talks about gay stuff a lot but
if you hear his personality he's just
joking around so it's kind of a
different kind of vibe it's not like he
hates gays or anything he's just playful
right and the guy played back like you
know with your mom you know he's gonna
hook up with his mom or something like
that and then he talked to uh john
morgan you know john murray from m
junkie yeah i love john he's a big dude
right he's a big dude always wears a
blue shirt so his son can see him on tv
so he was mentioning how like he didn't
go like hardcore in this fight because
he had people talking to him as well
like if you win this fight you know
you're gonna possibly fight for the
championship you know so then he was
telling john morgan like imagine you had
this house and you were full of burgers
and you can get to whatever kind of
messed up right something like that i'm
paraphrasing reference and food yeah
like food you would probably you would
work with your you know differently to
get there right and he's like no but i
love you fat shaming is like you when
you love someone if you want to train
with me i'll train with you this and
that so he's like being playful with him
as well that's just his personality i
heard a lot of people's feelings but
yeah for the most part i mean also in
the fight culture i don't think it's not
going to hurt anybody's feelings
the issue and i absolutely love and i
support sean strickling's uh behavior
the thing it's dicey is the mma media
and the rest of the fanbase
is cool with this we acknowledge this
this is it's a it's a exclusive because
we don't know his personality we're all
cool with it
but you get to the higher levels and
espn starts picking it up and then tmz
starts picking up and they start looking
into his background that's where this
becomes an issue yeah because
the outside of
you know your core group you'll realize
people are soft as [ __ ] and looking for
any reason to be upset so if you watch
this i'm sure it upset a few people the
fight fans we love it we know he's a
good person
that's that you know what most of the
time even with joe rogan 99 time
people don't know him they see a
headline
and they want to make assumptions based
off a headline not based off the person
but it goes both ways right it goes both
ways so for sean strickland keeps
getting more famous this stuff is going
to come out they're going to attack him
but the people that know him know like
he's a good person same with joe rogan
and then also i think
you know the left hack and joe and
they've
you'll see it's been a
it's been a calculated attack on joe
right now and it's it's been boiling and
it's boiled up to february and they
decided to pull the race card in
february that stuff they said has been
out forever everyone's aware of it that
stuff has been out forever you don't
think when he signed with spotify people
are aware of this stuff of course this
is a calculated attack and you can see
the slow boil and then it's
you know black history month what a
better time to spark this than black
history month you know and obviously i
don't
advocate what he said in any means and
you've never heard me say ever yeah i
don't [ __ ] with it even though the jokes
i don't like comedians do it on stage i
don't [ __ ] with any of it doesn't make
sense it hurts people's feelings it's
also super polarizing so
it's kind of like we talk politics in in
the audience half people are going to
love you half people are going to hate
you it doesn't make sense to me you want
everybody to love you so i've never
[ __ ] with it
you know joe's a grown man and that was
before i knew he was doing that stuff
so
you know if you look at what's going on
with joe it's very polarizing and i
think what the right or if you're a joe
rogan
advocator or supporter what you don't do
and you're going to start seeing it i
guarantee you start seeing it and to me
this is
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
is when you want to go
what about howard stern what about his
background should we go and do it and
it's horrible way worse
he's dropped the n word his treatment of
women like dude if you're going to
cancel anyone that would be a shoe it
that would be easy and serious is going
to have the world of questions to answer
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] man you know how easy
it would be for joe to go what about
howard sterner you look at the rock who
came out and defended rogan and then
backtrack a little bit right and then
they're attacking him now and yeah oh
what about your transphobic grant or
your asian rant you did
dude
as you can see left right middle
nobody's perfect but they're not bad
people i don't think listen i grew up on
hearthstone he's a
you know he's a
trailblazer he's one of the goats i used
to love him can't stand them now can't
stand him now he sits on his high tower
critiques everybody after he's made you
know more money than god he thinks he's
better than everybody you know if you're
not vaccinated you shouldn't have access
to the hospital just crazy [ __ ] man he's
in his high tower and condemning
everybody and he's changed his ways and
he's no longer the shock jock he's more
of a soy boy leader
but
i appreciate what he did back in the day
and i don't see him get canceled and the
world can't work like that oh this guy
said this but you said this and then
you're doing the same thing that you're
talking [ __ ] about this side you're
gonna do the same thing i don't think we
should work like that of course howard
stern said some terrible [ __ ] back in
the day times are different now he's
changed you want to talk about somebody
who's changed whether you agree with it
better or worse is it as entertaining no
not even close but he's definitely
changed he's dude he talks about the
therapy he's done he talks about all
that stuff he talks about how he would
certain markets he want to be the head
guy he'd go in a market one of the guys
commit suicide he bullied him so bad he
would go in and destroy these markets
because he wanted to be the top dog at
the time in the culture that was
acceptable
those were different times man
but you talk about a guy who again and i
don't [ __ ] with him in any facet now
especially once he went bad on rogan and
i was a serious subscriber not any more
men i can't stand the guy now we're
gonna be politically opposite i can't
stand him now he's no longer fun
now when he has a celebrity on still the
i don't have i don't hate anybody
i can still separate the two because
he's still to me the best interviewer in
the game when it comes to celebrities
there's nobody better him and mark
martin are the two best buy there's
fantastic rogan's great too but he
really doesn't do the celebrity
interview does he it's a conversation
yeah he's conversation you're gonna
learn something from it but he's not
going to have on the big celebrity just
get the views like these guys that's
what they do and that's fine rowan is a
different form of entertainment
i can appreciate all of them but i think
we got to be careful going well this guy
did this too or the rock did this too i
get it well those clips that you watch
with the rock he's a different guy now
he shouldn't be lose jobs or businesses
or opportunities because of these old
weird [ __ ] clips man it was a
different time whether the left right
middle
you got to look at the person now
because i and i think the spotify ceo
said it best goes
silencing joe rogan doesn't help things
it doesn't when you silence these people
it doesn't
and i also i view it like this and i
told joe this i talked to him yesterday
i told joe's this
spotify is on joe rogan's platform rogan
is not on spotify don't get it twisted
brogan can go anywhere in the world he
needs nobody and we've never seen an
animal like this not even close
he could go do his own thing which i
hope he does
you know there's a lot of things he
could do
they're not going to cancel but i think
he only has another year and a half left
on his contract so that's not a ton of
time
i think when it's over joe's going to
realize
this stuff only makes him bigger and
right now
right it's a lot of pressure
thank god he doesn't pay attention pay
attention to social media and what
people are saying about them right
but you weather this storm
and the people which is the majority of
america in the world realize joe's not a
bad person i can list off the amount of
people joe has helped in his life and it
would blow your [ __ ] mind and you
guys have no clue you have no clue
i don't [ __ ] with bad people i don't
have any person in my life in my circle
that is a bad person
zero
but if you read headlines about certain
friends that i have you probably think i
do associate that i don't if any of my
friends were actually what the internet
or social media thinks of if they were
actually that person
they dude i would [ __ ] cancel them so
goddamn fast and my life's not even
funny
i [ __ ] with no bad people
only good people hashtag only good
people in my life
out of all my people in my life there is
not a better person on this earth than
joe rogan
no one has done for more for my career
than joe rogan
and obviously that's the thing right oh
the only reason you're anywhere because
of joe sure again you know how many
people joe has helped out and they
didn't have my career or they didn't use
the opportunity and carry carry it and
turn into something great
more more
than other people that came successful
so that doesn't bother me but if i list
off the names black white asian female
whatever it is he doesn't there can be a
less less racist person on this earth
than joe rogan
i find it hilarious
i find my faith in humanity i find my
faith in
mainstream media is completely gone
after seeing the way they're treating
him it's insane to me
because the media will pick and choose
when you talk about misinformation
are you tell me who hasn't spread
misinformation has joe got all right god
no who tell me one
major network that you listen to that's
gotten every single right during this
pandemic
go i'll listen
tell me one person
that has had the conversations to move
the football down the field more so than
joe rogan
does he get all of it right no man
that's what makes this great is in real
time hope get it wrong and adjust
it's called being a human being and you
want to silence that why do you want to
silence it why did this
this whole
[ __ ] boiling point come to this thing
they've tried everything right they've
tried it misinformation transphobic now
it's racism they've tried it all man
and right now it's it's at its boiling
point and this will pass
and for the rest of america that don't
subscribe to what this cancer culture is
for the rest of the world they don't
subscribe to this toxic toxic silencing
of voices of brilliant minds
do you know what that does to a guy like
joe rogan it makes them bigger
and while cnn views are up or whatever
news network you watch i don't care who
it is they're up using the clickbank of
joe rogan and trying to hate on them
what happens in a month when this is no
longer a story
i'll tell you what happens your ratings
go back to where you were
where they're not [ __ ]
and what happens joe rogan
well humans
are gonna come up with their own ideas
and decide and look into it
and they're going to see oh he's a great
dude oh he's a smart guy oh he's
open-minded we said this a while ago now
he says that wow this is refreshing oh
wow it's an open platform where people
can discuss different ideas and have
different opinions but they're still
friends well this is crazy well we had
his buddies on their drinking and
smoking whoa i've never seen anything
like this what do you think happened to
joe rogan
he's 11 million now
i'd be willing to bet you i will [ __ ]
bet my bottom dollar when all the [ __ ]
is done he's at 20 million per episode
the biggest [ __ ] show of all time
so you're helping him you morons
so spotify is when you look at it is on
joe rogan's programming
everybody else on that thing everybody
else ain't [ __ ]
nobody has the power that he has
nobody's having the conversations have
because they can't
they don't have the open mind they have
an agenda
they have to have entertaining guests
rogan needs none of that he'll have a
[ __ ] sleep expert on and get more
views than you and i hated that episode
so how do you think this ends
what do you think is gonna happen
i will bet my last [ __ ] dollar on it
rogan comes out on top
bet against him man let me know how it
goes for you
because again this will be over in a
month and you cowards that refuse to say
anything because you worry about your
bottom dollar and you have an agenda
we'll see what happens
you want to side with neil young
you know you know he makes money selling
his catalog correct
he's not anti-joe rogan
he's pro money he's pro-capitalism
he went to amazon do you know just
recently
he sold his catalog for 150 million
dollars his back catalog
neil young's not making music he's not
streaming new music
any anybody under [ __ ] 67 years old
gives a flying [ __ ] about neil young
it's all his old catalog
this was his way of using joe rogan as a
launching launching pad to get to the
money he needed to get and he went to
amazon
but you're going to sit on your higher
moral ground and consider that a better
opportunity because of the joe rogan
spread misinformation you know they have
r kelly on spotify correct are you cool
with what he did you didn't say anything
about that
you're cool they sell bill cosby content
on there are you cool with that
you say anything about that so your
moral high ground doesn't mean [ __ ] this
was a money play that's all this is a
money play
look into it i'll use a famous eddie
bravo quote look into it and again i
will bet you any amount of money
who do you think comes out on top
these bottom feeders who want to
criticize and cancel joe rogan who's one
of the smartest minds one of the kindest
souls we've ever had on this [ __ ]
planet doesn't need to be doesn't need
anybody
just look at his body of work what he's
done with comics the comics he gives it
super opportunities to open and forming
from arenas males females
i won't say her name he had a female who
was just starting comedy and he had her
hosting rogan and friends sold out shows
four nights a week then brought her in
front of [ __ ] arenas
not because it's the cool thing to do
and he wanted to mix it up and have a
female voice because she's [ __ ] funny
and that's the way business and comedy
should work
the funniest person i don't give a [ __ ]
if you're trans
chinese
gay fat skinny in shape tattooed
cauliflower ears i don't give a [ __ ] if
you're funny you should get up there
over the people that aren't funny even
though they might be a different race
they might be a different
sexual orientation
that's not the way comedy works that's
the way sports works
that's the way hollywood works and how's
that going for you
how's it going for you guys
we have the power now
and when the talent realizes we have the
power you guys are [ __ ] straight up
we don't need anybody
we need nobody
you guys need us but you're gonna have
your puppets that play the game and have
to play the game they'll be around for a
little bit
but we're moving the marker and it
starts with joe rogan
and we're moving the marker with the guy
who's smarter more talented more kind
not racist
and richer than you
i'll bank on that guy
while the rest of you sit behind your
keyboard
and your board rooms and criticize
because you know what we're not gonna do
is go we'll look at what howard stern
said look what the rock said because
that's not moving the needle all that
does is cancel those guys we need those
guys i think rock's a fantastic person i
think the message and the hope they give
to people is fantastic i root for that
meat head i'm a meathead
i think joe rogan has changed the
narrative on meat heads but you guys
might say oh he's just this meat head is
he yeah he works out man
yeah he has a lot of muscle i hate to
tell you smarter than you he's more
open-minded than you
he's changing the world for the better
silence him makes this worse
if you have kids and i have two i have a
five and two-year-old
do you want to come up in a world where
the voices that are different than your
mainstream media get silenced
because they don't have an agenda and
can't sell your [ __ ]
vaccines is that what you want
or do would you like an open playing
field where your kids can learn and
listen from this perspective this
perspective and they come up with their
own decision doesn't that sound great
doesn't that sound great whether you
agree with what rogan has said
in the past whatever it is wouldn't you
like a world where your children grow up
and they're not sheep
and can listen to different perspectives
and then come up with their own identity
instead of pushing a false narrative
wouldn't that be great
well you have a guy who's doing that and
you're trying to silence him
and the world will not be better you
silence him and i hate to tell you
but you can't silence him this is a
fight you guys will not win in any facet
you're making him bigger
he's on every [ __ ] major headline in
the world right now and what's going to
happen is even people that don't [ __ ]
with them
let's say it's 100 million people 100
million people don't [ __ ] with them they
see the headlines and they tune in
this guy's pretty smart
this guy's pretty open-minded wow
he's actually really kind oh he's a dad
yeah he's a dad father of three oh wow
he's self-made hey self-made man holy
[ __ ] you signed the biggest deal in
podcast history yeah man
yup didn't even plan on it just started
doing it
just started doing it from his [ __ ]
bedroom and it blew up to the biggest
most powerful show in the world why is
that is it because
he's this hateful character hate never
wins
never wins like you list off a bunch of
comics and podcasters where all they do
is hate on other individuals their
numbers aren't great they don't do well
on the road
you have a small demo that [ __ ] with
that but in general the big boys the
guys who make it in this business are
kind hearted
they're open-minded and they're good
people for the majority of them they're
great [ __ ] dads
and how you base a person i don't give a
[ __ ] what business they're in what
profession they're in you judge them
based off the way they treat their kids
joe rogan has taught me so much in life
more than anybody else in my life
more so than anybody i've ever had in my
life and you know what he does he leads
by example
he's the best dad i know
i'm a [ __ ] beast of a dad i pride
myself on that
i learned that from joe rogan
open-minded apologizing
you gotta be careful apologizing though
cause that's what they want right you go
too much you lose this fan base
apologize for your mistakes but don't
apologize for being who you are
but again
this meathead
can apologize for previous mistakes
because he's open-minded and he's smart
enough to know he's made a mistake when
other people double down and never back
down that's not joe rogan
when i tell you guys
you're not gonna win this fight you're
[ __ ] with a different animal
that has a bunch of other [ __ ] lions
running with him
and we don't need hollywood we don't
need any of you
and our leader is the smartest
kindest
open-minded non-racist non-transphobic
guy you've ever met in your life and he
has all the money
so your [ __ ] move man what else you
got jen
deep man
all right
back to the fights um or fight news i
didn't want to get into the rogue and
stuff i said i was gonna save for a
fight
sometimes i gotta run with it man i mean
yeah we talked about the strong stricken
stuff and that that's what popped it off
so it's all good man those are authentic
natural this is a stuff we're in a phase
right now
when we come out of this fire and we
dust ourselves off who do you think's
gonna last man
it's not the people trying to silence
other people or have an agenda that we
can sniff that out it's never been more
clear
if i'm a major network if i'm cnn i'm
fox i'm
anybody netflix the nba these huge
organizations when you have an agenda
and people can smell it how's it going
for you ratings are down people aren't
[ __ ] with you
and i'm not even a huge trump guy not
any faster he polarized the nation
i like i like some of his stuff more so
than the left for sure some of his
policies stuff like that i [ __ ] with
that
i don't like any of them i think they're
all narcissists i don't like any
politicians you gotta be [ __ ] crazy
to be a politician they're all [ __ ]
narcissists
they're crazy you know
but when but over 70 million people
voted for trump
and i it could have been anybody but i
think the reason i vote for trump
because it's transparency
he's not he's not playing like the other
politicians do people are looking for
authentic human beings because we need
it now
more than ever
and you don't silence the authentics
and why do you think they want to
silence them
because they want their agendas
i'm not conspiracy guy this isn't
conspiracy this is hollywood this is
politics
and i'm telling you i have kids man it
bothers the [ __ ] out of me
you want to silence joe rogan are you
out of your goddamn mind
you can't he's uncancible hate to tell
you you should have tried seven years
ago you've let him get too big
his fan base knows him and there's
millions and millions and millions and
millions upon millions of people that
know joe rogan
because he's a podcaster comic he wears
his heart on his sleeve he cries for his
friends he cries for me when i fought in
the ufc he said this is too stressful
man i care too much about you gotta get
the [ __ ] out
he's a real person
anybody else you see in the spotlight
do you know [ __ ] about these
anderson cooper
or tucker carlson
or jimmy kimmel
jimmy fallon any of these other
names that have a voice in the space do
you know [ __ ] about them
no
the reason people [ __ ] with me is i was
just in atlanta
at the tough mudder there's so many dads
who come out to my shows they relate to
me off being a dad i talk about my kids
i'm very proud of them i've been told
from day one
from the most famous names in the game
don't post your family
that's the most important thing though
man i just where i like to show what i'm
proud of nothing makes me more proud
than my kids i post my [ __ ] kids
that's a dangerous world out there i get
it i take the necessary steps to protect
them but this is me man i don't be part
of social media if i can't post that
now some people just go check please and
they get out
and that doesn't help either like
aquafina you know her i love aquafina
they're coming after her for her black
accent
now if you watch a show or an interview
with aquafina she's this insane talent
she's so [ __ ] talented that's the
reason why hollywood scooped her up she
blew the [ __ ] up fast
if you would just take the time to look
into her background you realize she grew
up in an urban environment and all she
was was mimicking those around her
that's all this is she's not stealing
from the black culture she doesn't mean
to do it she's a product of her
environment growing up in new york
around [ __ ] urban
people
and that's why her accent's that way
she's not a bad person and it sh it
hurts me to see her go i'm getting away
from social media
i hate that now you [ __ ] double down
you tell your story
because the people that ride with you
that pay your bills that paid tickets
you know when you're on mulan she was or
not mulan what was the [ __ ] raya she
was the dragon voice on raya my kids
[ __ ] love her man they love raya they
love the dragon the dragon is hilarious
aguila finn is hilarious they're showing
comedy central she's a monster
you guys are applying so much pressure
to good people they're tapping out
and a lot of these artists and stuff
they're sensitive and they're going to
tap out
so he's not going to tap out sean
strickland
he's going to stay true to himself and
we [ __ ] with that good or bad i don't
agree with everything he says but i
appreciate how he's authentic i'll tell
you who's not going to tap out
and i will promise you to my [ __ ]
last dollars joe rogan
you met an animal that you can't beat
you've let him get too big he's too
strong he's too powerful
and it's not because he's pushed this
agenda this strength because he's a good
person and you guys know him he's been
podcasting longer than any of us
he's the godfather of huge podcast it's
him mark maron corolla
howard stern off sees a
disc jockey came up on radio but similar
he's talking
why do you guys why did you guys [ __ ]
with howard
from the beginning
because he was a savage man and he was
himself
and joe rogan is a savage and he's
himself he hunts he's a great dad
he's seen more [ __ ]
concussions than anybody in this world
you know and he rides that line he's a
guy and he wears a heart and sleeve he
buys cars he moved to texas
he doesn't subscribe to what you think
he he's a bernie sanders fan doesn't
make sense
doesn't make sense i can't believe he
had him on
but that's him because he likes him
you look at his guests alex jones
you know i wouldn't have alex jones on i
i don't that sandy hook stuff is
appalling to me i don't [ __ ] with any of
that
but joe rogan goes he's a good dude man
he [ __ ] up and he knows he [ __ ] up
he's a good dude that makes sense joe
still rides for him
how many of you out there if you're in
joe rogan's spot or my position would
still ride with your friends when the
rest of the world says not to
and why does he do it because we know
them you don't
i don't [ __ ] with anyone in my life
who's a bad person nobody
nobody there's not a [ __ ] chance man
life is too short to run with bad people
and i have kids man you think i'd bring
them around my kids if they're bad
people not a [ __ ] chance
joe wrong is the exact same
and that's why we will always come out
on top the good guy always wins
they say good guys finish last that's so
old man good guys finish first it just
takes longer
what do you got jen
okay so back to sean strickland but his
coach uh you you already mentioned that
the scorecard was kind of odd for one of
the judges sal diamato
and then this
is trust him just because of his teeth
i can't see his teeth
i don't trust that guy
i can't trust some teeth
i'm with his coach
based off his teeth you got it man uh
this is eric nick sick
not even one meet a member scored it for
jack i know we won but if this guy's
still judging he would continue to make
bad decisions the ultimate cause
fighters are critical i agree you can't
he can't have it and there's no nobody
holds their feet to the fire like oh man
terrible decision all right next week
ufc 271 sal out of motto or whatever the
[ __ ] is that motto he's messed up before
too of course but then there's no
repercussions there's nothing no one
talks to him it's just like oh another
bat it's the craziest thing in my it's
the crazy thing in my life
in the nfl
it was during the cincinnati raiders
game they made a terrible
call terrible call resulted in a
touchdown cincinnati won the super bowl
now love it
i can't i love jeff burrow uh burroughs
joe bro [ __ ] love joe bro love the
guy love his attitude love everything
about him glad he's in the super bowl
they probably shouldn't have been the
pressure lost that first game is the
raiders you know what the nfl did the
entire
uh referee
yanked him
you're out
no way man these games are too important
you really [ __ ] up you're out
what if we gave you know i there should
be some sanctioned body that looks at
the refereeing and fights and especially
don't even start [ __ ] boxing but in
mma i don't care about boxing i don't
i'll straight up tell you i don't give a
[ __ ] about boxing when i was showtime
they would have edited this out i've
always talked like this i hate to tell
you guys i've always said that i don't
give a [ __ ] i like the jake paul stuff i
like what he's doing i like the big
major pay-per-views when it's a
heavyweight i like when joshua wilder
fury fury's my favorite fighter in mma
or boxing i [ __ ] love fury because
he's authentic i love that i love when
canelo fights outside that tank davis
uh
lemachenko outside that
i don't give a [ __ ] neither do you guys
let's be honest
let's call it what it is we don't give a
[ __ ]
do we it's not as entertainers mma but
in mma house there's not a
sanctioned body that calls this sal guy
out and go dude what are you doing we
watched the fight how the [ __ ] did you
come up with that you got a six month
suspension man suspension exactly six
months yeah don't do this again happens
again you got a year suspension happen
you have three strikes happens here
you're out just like a fighter yeah
perfect hold them accountable like we do
the fighters yeah fighters uh test
positive six months depending right yeah
yeah do it again it's even better bigger
year they do if they're [ __ ] taking
all the juice it's two years
but the rafts can just make mistake what
other job what other profession can you
just make
horrible mistakes and then work the next
week
yeah
if i go on stage wednesday night at the
improv and i eat dicks they're not
having me back for quite some time
if i went to atlanta this past weekend
ate all the dicks they ain't booking me
next year
there's no profession where if you don't
do your job at a high level you can just
keep on keeping on it's only these
shitty refs and what's insane is they
have the ability to affect the pay and
the income of these fighters who are
scrounging for [ __ ] pennies man it's
nuts
six months suspension that [ __ ] idiot
yeah at least six months suspension
here's some [ __ ] money get your teeth
fixed boom
what else you got
also pay and also their future like the
trajectory of their future one decision
can mess it up
nuts right
oh this is actually pretty cool one of
the fighters got a hundred thousand
dollar bonus because his f the other
fighter missed weight first
yeah
that was pretty dope boy made some bank
yeah
your boy ben rothwell rothwell and
alexander griffithson in heavyweight are
fighting ufc fight night damn may 21st i
love that guy's return yeah i can't run
through still doing the goddamn thing
rothwell's so big
that's fun fight yeah
okay this i thought was interesting as
well so chad mendez
was discussing how the bkfc
he'd be making more money there than
ghana made in his last fight
so you're saying is that guaranteed or
is that only of pay-per-view sales i
think he said so i just saw the uc
heavyweight champion of the world just
got paid it's give me more than that
it's pretty crazy i feel blessed oh
that's cool
maybe just his actual pay i don't think
he's getting like pay-per-view points i
don't know no idea but then he also says
you guys have sponsorships too so that's
going to make a lot of money as well
yeah i get it you know france is making
good money off sponsors too i'd be
interested to see with with france's
sponsors and his pay-per-view if chad
still makes more either way it's an
issue but i mean
even if even if it's even [ __ ] close
it shouldn't be yeah talking about the
best bet on the [ __ ] planet you got
to pay the guy mm-hmm
uh which one he could wear stuff in in
the actual cage too which is a big deal
right
or ring whatever that is
so gilbert burns teased that uh
he's gonna have a fight with shania on
april 9th dude i do not like that fbi
for killing
so it says training camp officially
started and then so i assume he's gonna
get announced soon
srimaiv said gilbert
9th of april god
hamza
he just went from here
oh dude to the top i don't know who the
[ __ ] going to be i know
i don't think gilbert's going to beat
him sorry gilbert i don't think see who
they know
yeah
so holloway's cleared he had like an
undisclosed injury that's we had to pull
out of the volkanovsky fight so he's
cleared
and he's actually willing to get ready
to be a backup for the chan sun jung
korean zombie and volkanovsky fight
that's dope
uh
this i want your opinion on so bruce
buffer you kind of mentioned something
similar but not i did this thing not
yeah okay
so this is bruce buffer talking about if
in ghana decides to leave the ufc okay
here we go
bruce says it would be stupid to go your
own way the ufc is the nfl uh no offense
to other organizations but become
irrelevant when you leave the ufc after
a while to a degree
yeah
there's some truth to that right there's
100 percent truth for 99 of the fighters
there's truth to that now
can you make more money off just your
straight fight purse 100 percent there's
no argument there you can make more
money in other organizations if you're a
big enough name
the reason why francis is different and
bruce is wrong on this and you know i
love you bruce he did the commercial for
my [ __ ] special but the reason why i
love
um bruce he's right and i'm with you you
leave the ufc you just go off to this
obscurity and you know you make more
money but in the long run i'd be willing
to bet you don't make as much money
because nobody knows you're fighting and
you know you're i'm sure you walk down
straight around like oh what are you
doing these days no one really pays
attention to other leagues trust me
um
the only caveat here with francis is
francis has the opportunity to fight
tyson fury
so
francis is the one outlier here where if
he leaves ufc and i know for a fact that
francis is a real fight it's gonna
happen
you know you're talking about 40 50
million dollars and it will be
watched way more than any fight you
could have in the ufc so that's the
caveat here
i agree with bruce in general fighters
that leave we never hear from again even
though they're making more money it's
probably better in their household and
for their kids and all that [ __ ] that's
great i [ __ ] with that thank god
there's
other places to go but for francis the
caveat is
i can leave
and i can make not only way more money
but also get way more famous fighting
tyson fury so if that if the boxing
route was an opportunity for francis
bruce is 100
correct here but the truth matter is it
is and it's very viable it's very real
tyson wants that fight they're in
communications with the team i know this
for a fact i know for a fact tyson
called his team after the last fight
there's nothing more tyson wants than
the francis fight so it's gonna happen
you tell me that a francis tyson fury
fight wouldn't beat a francis stipe a3
fight
come on so bruce is off on this yeah but
in general bruce is correct
especially on that stance and also
francis left on top which a lot of
fighters they leave when they're
striving to like lose a lot but even but
even francis leaving on top if the tyson
fury fight wasn't an actual opportunity
that's gonna come to fruition i agree
even if you leave on top you're still
you're no man's land yeah america
especially america we do not if you're
not in the ufc we do not care
bring up any other organization's
numbers even compared to a [ __ ]
tuesday series contender on dana white's
espn plus those beat those
major cards bellator once you all these
other organizations have
you assignment they're not the ufc is
the nfl to a [ __ ] t dude
so even if francis were to leave and go
say to ryzen or one championship or
bellator as the champ and make more
money that's fine but you're not in the
ufc
we don't care we don't
hate to tell you guys we don't it's a
shame
right so this is anthony johnson anthony
rumble johnson's response to bruce he
says bruce needs to stay off the crack
how's anything irrelevant when providing
food and shelter for a family see so he
goes oh by the way i got paid way more
for moving to another organization bruce
has the guaranteed money so he can talk
fighters have to wait and actually
entertain people when they get the
chance to make some money
again from rumble's perspective he's
right he left and made more money
you're not addressing the point that
bruce is making when you left you didn't
get more famous you made more money yeah
bruce isn't arguing that you're not
going to make more money neither am i
you might make more money you might have
a better contract
you might
what we're saying is you're not in the
spotlight you're making more money but
you're irrelevant because you're not
getting the promotion of the ufc
he's right
i see why anthony be upset of course
he's he's not arguing the point bruce
made
bruce isn't saying you're not gonna make
more money he's not saying i can provide
for your family and stuff like that in
shelter we're not saying any of that i'm
saying if you're not in the ufc
people don't pay attention that's what
i'm saying definitely not as much and
i'd love to see the numbers that prove
otherwise
ego
all right uh let's go to this one i'm
sure you're excited about this they
finally announced the time that amanda
nunes speaking of irrelevant
i mean julian pena and amanda has huge
names both relevant as far as
if you want to be forgotten about
be the coach of the ultimate fighter
yeah you would get more views just make
an appearance on [ __ ] tuesday night
contender series nobody's watching the
ultimate fighter nobody
i don't get why they're so weak but
whatever i don't know why they need to
do it it has to be a contractual thing
must be so they're gonna do it it's
gonna go on it's gonna debut tuesday may
3rd and then after that they'll do the
rematch sure yeah
near future so that's the good part
three match mm-hmm
um so another quick one on there's a few
on women's image just quick ones here
amanda knew that she remember she left
suddenly from att did her own gym and
remember i said the caveat here is if
she leaves does the team go with her you
can start your own gym but if you have
the same coaches we're all good now if
you leave and none of them come with you
have all new staff that's where this
gets dicey okay not sure about who the
coach is going to be but she says she
wants to become a coach so that's why
she wants to kind of start off brand new
and it's going to be like a private gym
rather than
like ruka ruka does that now yeah
and
i'm still curious about it which coaches
are involved yeah then i'll make an
opinion
cluster shields asked
on this
yeah i'll just play it that's quick that
would be great for her
so who knows such a good coach
that's what i want like i feel like i'm
missing like that's the biggest part i'm
missing right now like i feel like of
course boxing we're on point i can throw
good kicks and all the chick kicks and
recognize when they're coming
um
it's just with the wrestling like the
level change you go from up here from
fighting and then they go for your legs
you got to be able to recognize that go
for this ball and stop the take down so
i really want to work with you
i will hear you that'd be cool i'm
wearing yeah she's doing a smart move
harry's working with everyone now yeah
he's a beast shout out to henry sudo
another quick one here this is david
figueroa saying he wants to change the
game up with the light awaits and then
for the next the rematch he's saying a
million dollars
payday for him i'd have to see what
their numbers did the first one i'm sure
the ufc is saying the same thing what
else you got and then uh so brandon
responded with this i had to go to
google translate
a million a
and pay-per-view points when they don't
want to see you even at your house
somebody's saying you don't want this
fight
oh that [ __ ] he's like dude i thought
he's like what no he's like you're
making all these demands you just don't
want the fight okay you know damn well
we get a million plus pay-per-view
points come on
that's what he's saying he's like dude
come on you just don't want the fight
when guys give it's based like uh uh
costa being like you know i only want
this or i'm out it's like okay you just
don't want to fight that yeah
yeah gotcha
all right just a quick one now i'm a
little late to this but did you see
cyril gone playing basketball uh this is
pretty damn impressive these athletic is
oh yeah so here's him doing a slam dunk
at some area
oh it's too easy for him yeah and then i
saw more footage here
can you shoot you can shoot watch
yeah damn
[Music]
i don't like how it says sirogon plays
basketball like a pro you ever seen a
pro
i mean he's making shots with no one in
his face i know and then check this last
one out i thought this was the most
impressive so jesus christ i don't know
for a fact but everyone's saying that
sin that's got to be him right it's just
like yeah 100 that's him
why the [ __ ] wouldn't that be him
he's stupid athletic
boom
too easy for him
yeah he's a monster he's easy
athletically he's the best in the ufc
the size and stuff if only he wasn't
born in france he playing d-line for the
[ __ ] bengals right now making stupid
money but you grew up in france and they
don't play that there so
he can punch the face for a living
yeah but crazy yes well he's a freak is
that it that's it all right kids ufc 271
is this mother trucking saturday izzy
versus robert whittaker your co-main
event derek lewis tied to ivasa there
will be a fight companion crystalia
brian kelln super special guest and
myself starts at 7 p.m only on thick boy
youtube the audio feed will be up later
but uh to watch it live with this 7 p.m
available only live on thick boy youtube
uh other than that man bunch of funny
kids
uh we got a bunch of calabasas uh
classic fight campaigns this week we
have the big super ball thick boy uh
football super bowl companion i will
release news on that once the graphics
are ready to go it is completely
different than anything you guys are
used to it's me and it is not brian it's
not chris it is two very very special
guests i think you guys will be excited
about that will be streaming as well i
think at 3 p.m pacific sunday super bowl
companion not in thick boy studio it's a
really big event so i'm excited for that
i will announce that as we get closer um
cats have dark is available right now on
thick boy youtube and audio as well
and uh yeah man we're doing the goddamn
thing
uh this wednesday shop and friends uh 30
tickets left shop and friends crystalia
brian callan jeff dye chappelle lacy um
we got monsters there we got monsters
shopping friends one show only 8 p.m 30
ticks left hollywood
california hollywood improv wednesday
night february 9th and then uh on sale
right now sacramento california is
february 24th through 26th
sac town come get some i'm at the punch
line with the crew february 24th through
26th just announces nashville tennessee
zany's one of my favorite clubs in the
world that is zany's nashville tennessee
march 10th through the 12th then chicago
is march 24th through the 26th get your
tickets right now thickboy.com
and also subscribe to the supercast go
to thickboy.com for any of the merch
any of my show tickets thickboy.com the
supercast is there click on the premium
shows and you can go from there the
reason i went with super cast is because
it is the by far
the easiest subscription thing to do it
uploads already to your feed whether
it's spotify itunes we send you a link
to watch the video ad free we have
exclusive content on there all my shows
are ad free just go to thickboy.com
click on the premium content and sign up
from there it's easy to do all right
all right kids love you hollywood i'll
see you this wednesday sack you're up at
the end of the month love you guys till
next time stay thick